prior to the pandemic we had a full
house it was wall-to-wall people in here
all the time
and then on march 16th we closed
and we've had no customers in here since
then
in mid-march gleason's boxing gym like
gyms and fitness centers across the
country
closed because the pandemic now after
roughly half a year on pause
gleason's preparing to reopen its doors
instead of coming in
at your whim you have to come in through
appointment only
and the employees will all have to have
a covert 19 test
everybody that walks in will have to
immediately use hand sanitizer we'll
also take their temperature
new york state has provided gym owners
with 35 pages of protocols
they'll have to follow if they want to
reopen but it still isn't clear
what the new normal for gyms will look
like will clients return to their old
routines
or will the pandemic have a lasting
impact on our workout habits
simply put how might the coronavirus
pandemic transform the fitness industry
the american fitness industry has been
upended by covet 19.
24-hour fitness and gold's gym filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy
after missing out on membership dues the
parent company of new york sports clubs
and lucille roberts gyms
have also warned of potential
bankruptcies carbon 19
pandemic has created severe shock to the
things
to this industry to the operators this
is the industry that
derived majority of the revenue from
monthly membership
right so when the gyms were forced to
close
in mid-march the revenue stream had gone
it was really zero revenue coming in
while you still have huge lease
obligations
as well as the labor cost so the company
all of a sudden running to severe stress
according to o'brien before the pandemic
many chains borrowed heavily
to expand aggressively issuers that
cover a majority of them
are owned by private equity firms and
the private equity firms their smart
money
and they're attracted to the industry
for two reasons primarily
number one is the recurring nature of
the membership you have a very reliable
steady stream of months monthly revenue
coming in
and number two there's this long-term
fundamental
demographic shift of focus on fitness
and wealth
and as much as we think that people go
to gyms
but you know in terms of percentage of
people
actually belonging to gym memberships
it's still in the low 20
for the u.s so there's still a huge
growth trend
but the pandemic has changed the math
they're stuck with very expensive leases
that no worth in the old time it doesn't
really work in the new normal
it's a huge problem one gym that has
been spared the worst of the pandemic is
planet fitness
the biggest chain in the country there's
not many other businesses out there
that through this had zero revenue since
we've shut down cause they'll take out
food there's no
delivery service i mean this whole
industry has zero revenue you know
luckily
we're our franchise system a lot of
sophisticated franchisees multi-store
operators which has really helped us
they might have five 10 or 25 plus
stores in multiple states which has also
helped us so they might have some
clothes in new york still but
have clubs in florida they've been open
for a while so that's really helped us
along through this
a chance to grow stronger one of the few
areas of growth in the fitness industry
during the pandemic has been at-home
classes
with gyms closed many americans not
[Music]
we've available in the last few years is
technology is really transforming this
industry
you started with companies like peloton
right a few years ago they started
offering at home you can buy
a peloton bike and pay a monthly
subscription about 40
and have access to their own demand as
well as live
classes so this pandemic with
lockdown measures their home measures
remote working
really accelerated this at home workout
trend
yeah i mean home fitness is not new it's
just richard simmons and jane fonda then
it was
ty beau with billy blanks and then it
was p90x that's always been here
i do however think that this has
accelerated the um
adoption of digital whether it's in club
auto club i think people now realize
that they can utilize this
and and learn how to exercise better get
the most of their membership in clubs
in that home back in brooklyn
bruce silverglade remains committed to
gleason's despite the challenges
he's faced during lockdown the pandemic
has taken a tremendous toll on me
emotionally and physically the monthly
expense
has been about 36 000 the monthly income
has been zero so the only way that i've
been able to stay
afloat is to use some of my personal
monies
and to borrow money from the bank and
this
has been uh something that is new
uh to me and to gleasons prior to the
pandemic
i was debt-free you know big expense
again was my my rent and my payroll
other than that i had no no bills and
now when this is over
and i get back to uh to business i'm
probably going to have a 200 000
debt despite gleason's being a small
independent gym
silverglade is confident it will survive
but few independent gyms are likely
since the brooklyn-based boxing gym
is one of the best-known boxing gyms in
the country if not the world
i don't want to get sick okay i'm 74
years old i have diabetes
so there's no way in the world i want to
have people come in here and inflict
covert 19 on anyone or on me gleasons
will not close i won't allow off to
close
but i'm going to you know have a have a
huge debt